[Music]
so I think maybe we can start by giving
the audience some context about quantum
metric can you tell us a little bit
about how it got started and you know
your push to the cloud yeah absolutely
so we started in 2015 and really the
idea I started my career in retail in
the early 90s I think it's been a bit a
while and there's this magic that
happens when you walk into a store and
you are seeking to purchase some
specific good clothing or jewelry I
started my career out in the retail
clothing industry you could be buying an
airline ticket engaging with a bank and
there's this special touch that we've
perfected over millennia that when I'm
had that physical engagement with a
person I can understand when they have a
need when they are looking for help from
an associate or etc and as we have
progressed on to digital how do we
deliver these incredible unique
experiences these touches that we have
in our physical engagement how do we do
that well online and so that was the the
challenge that we set out to do and you
know there's a picture here of what it
looked like in 2015 and maybe some of
you that are in startups can relate to
this to this this is you know two guys
in a room with a Kanban board just
chugging away at code and design so it
was a really fun fun start back in 2015
we've gone a long way since then and so
we've had some incredible success so
just to kind of catch up and just in the
last year we've had 400 percent growth
year over year we've had been fortunate
enough to take twenty six million
dollars of funding and we have 80 plus
experts around the world to help our
customers engage in delivering their
their their best on digital and that was
your series a funding that seems like a
big number it was about that a bit yeah
you know we've had so much success at
enterprises engaging with some of the
best brands United Airlines Alaska eBay
Western Union stuff Ticketmaster
Matthew we've had such an incredible
engagement of how we empower those large
enterprises at delivering their best on
interferon on digital and when you get
that kind of you know success with the
largest of brands and even being a small
company there's some excitement and so
with that we were fortunate enough to to
have one of the the best venture firms
out there you know a private equity is
inside venture partner so really blessed
to have so much success at an early
stage great and is that is that your
team in a queue formation how long did
it take you to do that yeah so we like
to have a lot of fun at quantum and so
this one is just one of our our team
get-togethers and we all we threw up a
drone and it's quite fun so so I think
one of the great things about startups
and you know really anyone's workplace
it's gonna have a lot of fun so we do
that here at quantum so see you had two
people in that 2015 photo and now you've
grown and talk about your push to the
cloud and where you started compared to
now yeah so you know I think we all have
our strengths and weaknesses I know my
weakness is not you know it's not about
I don't design infrastructure I don't
design data centers and so I'm
embarrassed to show this picture but
literally this is just last week our
quote data center on Prem in our
Colorado Springs office and the funny
story about it recently is that there
was a bomba Genesis there was a big
storm in in Colorado Colorado Springs
and we literally had to get someone to
drive a few miles in a crazy storm to
hit a power switch somewhere in this
closet for our development tools so as
we were all work from home you know we
got the support that we needed so this
is how I know that we weren't meant to
have an on-prem solution but there are
some other reasons too we have wait but
before I jump into some of the other
reasons I guess our journey really began
with with the same journey that most of
the folks that have onboard of
themselves on the Google cloud have have
engaged with and it was really about we
knew as a data analytics company we're
gonna have massive amounts of scale
coming in and how would we be able to
Alaska lease kale we didn't have at the
time tens of millions of dollars of
funding to go build and
in a crazy data center to handle that
level of scale and at that at the at the
end of the day how do we get folks that
are in financial services industries
that are massive retailers how do we get
them comfortable with deploying onto our
platform when we talk about security and
and privacy and GPR and really great
challenges that we face and technology
how do we get them comfortable with that
and knowing that that Google literally
has laser beam protected floors like we
don't have them in our office I don't
know if you have them in yours but but
but also you know even down to custom
built embedded hardware to make sure
that the hardware hasn't been tampered
with and it's not been hacked etc which
if you've been seeing the news it
happens and so how do we get our
enterprise customers comfortable with
that level of security so that was kind
of the beginning of our journey and I'm
excited to share a little more today
about where we kind of fell into there's
much more to cloud than just I would
almost say these menial things of hey
look we can have reduced costs we can
scale quickly these are these are maybe
table stakes but there are some really
cool things that help us think different
about the challenges that we face and
that we saw for our enterprise class
right and and just for the audience is
anyone familiar with seeing that closet
photo in your own offices I'm sure it's
pretty common and we're also familiar
with that need to scale very quickly in
a short amount of time can you elaborate
more on this amount of scale of traffic
and data that you've seen a quantum yeah
I'm super excited
I love scale I'm passionate about taking
on a large amount of data and how to how
do we ingest it and actually get
insights from it so a typical month at
quantum we will take in over 600 million
sessions so to give you to put that in
perspective it's about 300 million
unique visitors and that's about one
ninth of the Internet that's one ninth
of the folks that are online we also
take 89 billion HTTP requests and that's
to put in perspective of scale about
one-fifth and number of queries that
Google search handles in a given month
so massive amounts of scale we handle
one and a half petabytes of network
traffic a half a petabyte of cloud
storage and over 14 petabytes of
bigquery analysis so this is just an
overwhelming amount of data it kind of
like just an onslaught of information
and you know what was fun about cloud is
how do we build an infrastructure to do
that we don't need to we can hit a
couple buttons in Google console and
scale and and we have some incredible
retailers I mentioned earlier imagine a
Black Friday I know retin-a car
yesterday was talking about Kohl's and
his experience in cloud and being able
to scale so quickly I mean imagine the
day that you need to handle three to
five times your normal workload and you
just hit a switch it was pretty exciting
and how we can engage in cloud and have
so much success with so much ease right
yeah and this can't be an easy challenge
you know how are you able to support
this amount of data traffic over a
petabyte yeah so it's you know they have
this massive scale how many of you have
been involved with big data projects and
and how many of you have had incredible
insights coming out of those big data
projects so from so for the the viewer
audience not that many right it everyone
kind of put their hand down and so we
collect incredible amounts of data but
no one cares about what you collect I
don't care about hoarding information or
hoarding things I care about what
insights can I deliver from that data
and so that's where that massive scale
analysis really comes into play and so
when we when we talk about you know us
as a company and and how to get great
data how to get great insights from it I
like to relate it to flying an airline I
know all of us and many of us have flown
here but many of us fly often and when
I'm flying to Iceland today and I'll
tell you I didn't buy the jet to take
that flight to Iceland I'm buying a seat
right and so with our sporadic workload
so we have folks coming in to our
console and trying to in our platform
and trying to look at insights some
questions they want to answer are they
doing well is their hybrid cloud it
performing well or is their on-prem and
and their cloud solutions performing the
same or even better in cloud they have
questions they want to answer but it's
sporadic it's not constantly in our
platform asking questions so it's
sporadic it's very similar to I need to
take a flight somewhere I need a very
small amount of compute power or a large
amount of compute power for a small
amount of time I don't need to take I
don't need to buy the jet I want to see
on the airline so we had that same
challenge with our workload and what's
really exciting is how the cloud can
empower this and we realized quickly
that our success is really about how do
we ingest this data and find novel ways
to present insights from that large
amount of data set and that was what was
going to differentiate us it wasn't
about how we collected it wasn't about
how it looked in our console is what
insights can we deliver for our
customers right yeah and and this data
scale is handled by bigquery as you
mentioned and a lot of our customers at
Google cloud are doing very innovative
things with bigquery at the moment but
as many people know it's not the only
data science platform you know there are
other vendors that offer other solutions
you mentioned a really funny story about
your son earlier do you mind telling the
audience about that story yeah so I was
poor I was writing an article for Forbes
about our experience in cloud and and
different takeaways that we've had at
massive scale and I was writing about
BIC worry and about how it's been
transformational for our business how
we've been empowered empowering our
customers to have new insights that they
never even knew that they could ask some
automation about the processes that they
discover where frustration is happening
online and it's hilarious because my
nine-year-old son is name is Cody he
seriously says to me but Dad can Amazon
and Microsoft do this to you it's kind
of like bummed away but he knew the
names of the other two large cloud
providers and you know it's funny that
you asked this Cody absolutely like I
really believe that Amazon and Asher
right AWS and Asher can can deliver on
massive scale compute and massive scale
data analysis but the challenge that we
have is our workload is sporadic and I
don't want to spin up let's say 50,000
CPUs to do an analysis it might take a
minute or two to spin up run my query
for five seconds and shut it all down
it's just it's not financially feasible
and so you know I think one of the
really unique differentiations of google
cloud has been this fractional lease of
analysis of a big compute to chug away
at massive scale of data and I want to
talk a little bit about some of the
other things that we we believe that
massive compute brings to the table when
it comes to thinking different about
about data analysis but for us and what
I told my son was absolutely but
fractional leasing has been a
differentiator and I think if you have
either used bigquery or if you know
folks that are they'll talk to you about
that that same fractional lease that
massive amount of query capabilities for
a small period of time is really one of
the unique features of a bigquery and
the title of the session is apples 1997
promise to think different can you talk
more about what you mean by that how are
you thinking different with your teams
right now yeah so this is one of the
best marketing campaigns of all time and
you know I know from looking at the
audiences there's some of us that have
probably remember this campaign very
well and it was talking about you know
apples engineering fortitude and
likening it to geniuses that were brave
enough to take on the world and change
it it may be crazy enough I think the
words were crazy enough to try to change
the world and actually accomplished it
but it wasn't about buying an Apple
computer and all of a sudden you thought
different it was simply like we think
different like these geniuses what I
thought was amazing and where I came up
with this concept was like when we
engage with bigquery we basically took
our handcuffs off these handcuffs we had
no idea existed in terms of massive
scale query analysis we could start
asking questions that we never thought
about asking because now we didn't have
any rails we didn't have indexes we
didn't have certain types of queries
that we could run we could run a
question across a day a month a year and
start getting insights that we never
really knew about so my belief is that
we are now able to think different about
how do we solve business problems for
our customers for our enterprises in
ways that we never really explored right
I think you also talked about machine
intelligence a bit too right yeah so you
know one of the things that we
discovered you know and you know we're a
start-up we went from you know just a
few years ago from two people to you
know 80 plus today you know as that
journey happens you start to learn for
me a little bit about that selling
process and you know we used to talk and
I think it's kind of funny because Apple
never really talked about the
performance of the CPUs and all the
metrics of memory stuff that you know
kind of techies that we think about may
think about we should share this what
what I learned was no one really wants
this concept about machine
telogen so we can talk about AI machine
learning no one really cares about that
they just want intelligence they just
want answers to their their challenges
in their and their business needs and so
that was you know a journey that we went
on and started figuring out that we can
help customers automate some of those
human processes some of the things that
they do and they spend hours or days we
can take massive scale compute and solve
them perhaps in seconds yeah yeah and
machine intelligence here how can you
talk about some of the examples that
you've gone through at your company how
are you able to implement this type of
practice and thinking yeah so we've been
able to take some of the things that
we've really software our customers have
been when I go to a web site and I'm
having a bad experience how do I know
about I don't fill out surveys I don't
call the company and tell them hey your
website's broken I just leave so how do
we figure out people are having a bad
experience and when it turns out we can
look at their behavior they're they're
clicking reload they're hitting the back
and forward button their rage clicking
the book of flight or transact button
and we can look at those behaviors and
with bigquery you can start aggregating
around those behaviors and discover
these lead to under conversion and so
we've automated that process of
discovery and build that sort of human
discoveries human analysis into our
product so it's been really
transformational for our for our
enterprise customers because they don't
have to spend days wandering it's just
actually impacting my business they can
know about it in seconds another
fantastic one was the ability to
understand when did a problem actually
start occurring and for our enterprise
customers they had no way to know when
the bug was introduced into their system
they would they would spend days looking
at logs and looking at released notes or
trying to figure it out what we're able
to do is spin up tens of thousands of
CPUs in cloud functions and Google
compute to analyze when did this start
happening by replaying every session
that visited the website
when did the indicator of the issues
start occurring so with massive scale
compute we started solving problems that
our enterprise customers had never even
broached because they just didn't have
50,000 100,000 CPUs lying around in the
data center so it's really been amazing
how cloud has enabled us to think
different about some of the challenges
that these enterprises we're facing and
I think another one that's been really
you know a hot topic for us in our space
has been how do we take the highest
standard of care with our customer data
and a lot of it was left to human
configuration we know we're sensitive
information was we know where there's
PCI information or PII and either
encrypt or mask it the problem with that
has always left it up to human error and
how often was someone looking at this
type of data and discovery you know and
that discovery would happen we needed to
automate that so we're now engaging with
Google's the sensitive data API and
rolling this out hopefully in the next
short time period about instead of
waiting for cut for humans to discover
that there's miss configuration can't we
just have the computer tell us that
here's an opportunity to improve the
data that we're collecting so that
that's it's just really great waste in
exciting ways that we can gauge in
machine learning massive scale compute
massive scale query analysis to automate
some of the functions that we had to do
as humans yeah and I think a lot of our
audience probably wants to know how they
can implement these practices into their
own organizations as well can you talk
about some exemplary use cases for them
to do this yeah I think I think there's
a there's not a prescriptive way that
you can take this and bring it home to
your all of your own organizations you
have to take a look at what are some of
the human processes that we can automate
and and as you engage in cloud scale and
think about compute in different ways I
do believe it will help you think
differently about some of the massive
problems that that you engage in at your
enterprises and startups alike and so
here's that my thought process is a very
simple process and it's just literally
the process that we took to discover hey
how can we automate some of these
processes with massive scale compute and
it's really about where are their tasks
that we face that consume a lot of time
how can we translate that into a set of
queries you know how can we take a look
at this massive scale data and
understand here's how we automate that
process identifying key insights what
will make people engage in in these
results I give for us it was about
revenue if we can talk about if you do
this you'll make 17 million dollars
that's when people started saying okay
these are insights that I want
listen to verses hey here's some graphs
and charts thank you for the anecdotal
evidence I'm gonna go on about my
priorities in my daily job so when we
can connect that with revenue that's
what really people start to engage in
that those those results and then just
you know engaging across team so we
learned a little bit about cross team
and and maybe the the interception of
domains where we believe that this is
where creativity is really born and so
we can get product teams and engineering
and DevOps and business teams and
executive teams all aligned on where the
biggest impacts are for their business
we can start to make a what we believe
to say the words digital transformation
because those words mean a little bit
different for each company but
additional transformation on on having
everyone aligned on where are my biggest
successes for my organization and how do
we get everyone to take action as
opposed to you know maybe confirmation
bias or everyone having their own
agendas so that's been pretty exciting
so following that that recipe success
we've had about three or four iterations
on how do we think different about our
data and I think it's something that the
audience could take away thank you yeah
I think thank you so much for sharing
the some of those wins that you've
gotten with Google cloud and kind of
enabling our audience to be able to
achieve their own digital transformation
awesome Oh Stephanie it's a pleasure
being here and thank you all for for
attending all right thank you everyone
[Music]